the greatest of all time here we go the
Epic Trilogy fight for the first time
ever Demetrius Johnson defends the one
flyweight World Championship in the USA
one fight night 10. Johnson versus
Marias 3 on Prime video
and I think the narrative the media ran
with it like DJ's final fight I'm like I
haven't heard him say that
yeah yeah and I think you know where
that narrative came from I mean it could
be my last fight right like you said you
you're an athlete you've fought before
you I'm sure you've had these feelings
come arise in your training camp when
you're getting for your next your next
fighting for me you know I'm human these
are my emotions that I feel you know
what I mean and when when is it time to
call it when do you walk away from the
sport and uh it's something I never you
know charted on before
now Brandon
oh shy what's up brother
my beautiful day man it's big time yeah
man you look good what do you use
moisturizer Jesus it can't be the the
altitude out there man that's dry as
[__] your skin is fantastic I have a
great skin routine so I use moisturizer
and get the beard moisturized so yeah
moisturized baby how do you not have a
beard sponsor at this point or do you
I don't you know I do have a thing on a
manscape but that's only one one-time
deal so I don't know why maybe you can
talk to somebody give me hooked up yeah
I'll talk to the boys over at manscape
you should be the face of manscape Jesus
dude I do a lot of interviews I do a lot
of interviews with dudes on here and
your face is distractingly smooth man I
think I appreciate that so you got to uh
Denver early smart man because the
altitude out there how early are we
talking
[__] April 18th can I hear April 18th
right after I hit New York I came right
out here and we trained Dwayne ludwigs
for about a week and a half two weeks so
I feel like it feels like two weeks
and now we're at The Host Hotel finish
up the outfit so I know not all before
we fight it might be two and a half to
close to three weeks you should be good
because usually they say you know I'm
from Denver so usually they say it takes
about two weeks to get acclimated to the
you know to the the air up there you
should be fine also it's not like you've
ever had a freaking issue with cardio I
figured I figured even for a guy like
you I mean at this level though
especially the guy you're fighting I can
see why you get early but it's never
been a thing for you
yeah I thought here back in 2009 or 10
when I bought Nick Pace back in WC and I
came out here two weeks and private and
it felt fine but you know I I didn't
want to you know take any chance I know
my cardio is always great so
I I was like nah let's get out here Tony
for one time of the year just get out
shooting me and go out there compete
yeah you fought Nick Pace in 2010 wec in
Broomfield so this is the last time you
were there now you're back and you're
the it's kind of groundbreaking because
the first time one Championship is
hitting the soils here in the United
States kind of a big deal man we had uh
chatri and Mikey here in studio at thick
boy on firing the kid and uh it just it
just feels like so you can feel it
there's like something big around this
event you know do you feel any pressure
being the main event not that you've
never you know that's your thing you're
the main event guy the you're the goat
so it's your thing but this one's a
little different because it's you know
it's a new organization there's a lot
riding on it Mikey was a little stressed
out you know because he's like I think I
feel man I'm doing a jiu jitsu match for
God's sakes
yeah I mean I think he definitely has
more pressure than I do because this
martial arts has already already been
established here in the states right
like it's everybody knows Big Time mixed
martial arts then I'm also like you said
I've headlined big cards in the States
you know in California Vegas
Toronto and even on San America I mean
it is America but it's in Canada so for
me it's no added pressure I think for my
teeth he probably feels that pressure
because you know Grandpa isn't always
the biggest thing to the Mixed Martial
Arts American community in general right
like you watch you know the UFC or
Bellator or whatever maybe when they see
people start grappling they're like
standing up
rip his head off stand him up so I I
think Mikey you might feel a little bit
of bad pressure but I think once they
see Mikey and you know rotoler brothers
and RDR go out there and grapple and it
just offers something different you know
I tell everybody like you know one
Championship is like going to a party
and there's multiple things on the menu
instead of when you watch you know the
other organizations here in America you
you get one fixed menu it's chicken
that's all you're gonna get mixed
martial art for one Championship you can
Muay Thai kickboxing MMA Jiu Jitsu and
maybe even hopefully in the future maybe
a boxing fight again yeah I think you're
supposed to the way this card lines up
you got you on who obviously the
American crowd's familiar with and then
if people don't know they're gonna know
with Rod tank they need to know with Rod
tank here in America that dude is a
straight Savage and then with Mikey too
you know he was saying how he feels
pressure but also in this camp like he
it's been attack attack he's like well
I'm not just gonna sit on my butt and do
things like I know you know what's at
stake here and I'm we're gonna make this
exciting and his uh opponent Osama also
understands the stakes so they're going
to put on a show so I'm excited for it
here's here's the narrative this and
it's this this is credit to you this is
how powerful you are right now is
the rumor came out rumor I mean not a
rumor you started that this might be
your last fight I call [__] I don't
I don't feel that you tell me if I'm off
on this I was talking to the team before
it could be you know what I'm saying
that it could be at your level it's like
you could fight to your 44 like you know
you're doing the damn thing so it's like
yeah the last one could have been your
last one but it's not like yeah it's not
like almost a miles situation where we
know like at Don Cerrone where we know
it's the last one it's like yeah maybe
and I think the narrative the media ran
with it like DJ's final fight I'm like I
haven't heard him say that
yeah yeah and I think you know where
that narrative came from I mean it could
be my last fight right like you said you
you're an athlete you've fought before
you I'm sure you've had these feelings
come arise in your training camp when
you get over your next your next fight
and for me you know I'm human these were
my emotions that I feel you know what I
mean and when when is it time to call it
when do you walk away from the sport and
uh it's something I never you know
charted on before right I've had these
feelings before but I've never actually
expressed them to the public and talk
about it and for me you know when I look
guys like GSP have been rid of the other
guys who've walked away from this sport
those two they didn't walk away from the
sport when they were losing right like
time will they he walked with me sport
when he was losing
um you know Donald Trump's same thing
yeah all these guys
when they were they were walking away
when they were losing yeah for me yeah I
could buy one episode 40. I'm healthy
I'm still fast way is great I love
dieting I love training I love competing
but there has some important time where
the the athletes take a step back I'm
okay you know
like hey your brand is Big you've pretty
much accomplished everything in mixed
martial arts so when you can't buy
forever so when are you going to make
that step to start focusing on other
things outside of the next martial arts
also when you look at GSP he just he
became a world champion you know a lot
of people are talking about how he
receive
um you know always come back after three
years it's never been done before it has
been done before GSP did it uh we were
the champion he beat Johnny Hendricks he
was all bruised up he was gonna take
time away from the sport I'm gonna
retire then he came back and beat
Michael Bisping became a champ and then
he left again so he could have kept on
fighting maybe he could I haven't talked
to him yet but I I plan on reaching out
to him and then you know I and I think
he's kind of set when he's like his
father passed he promises mom he's a man
of his word yep so for me it's I think
having like you said the immediate ran
with it as a great narrative killing my
last fight and sure it could be my last
fight
um you're not just fine to sit down
relax and talk to the wife and just see
what we want do
yeah I think too like the sacrifices
that you have to make to in order to get
to at your level you know and to be
considered one of the goats the the
expectations the sacrifices you have to
make and you have kids you know you got
kiddos you got a wife so it's like how
long do you want to sacrifice you know
because you're in Denver now you've been
there for two weeks well that means
you're not dropping the kiddos off at
school not picking them up you know
they're all that stuff's important man
you know trust me I get it yeah I deal
with it with with torn but it kills me
man when I have to leave but at your
level you know you got to make those
sacrifices so at some point it's like I
guess my question for you is like what
else is there to do obviously you enjoy
competing you're at the highest level
but when I I and I look at the roster at
one Championship I'm like all right who
beats Marias who's this absolute Savage
beat him again that chapter is over
you know so I guess I was trying to put
myself in your shoes I'm looking I'm
like what else would he do it could be
that you know or maybe take some time
off and wait for contenders to earn
their keep and get get the names and
then you come out of the shadows and
beat the [__] out of them
nah for me you gotta keep it going to
keep you know I want to sit down and
wait if I sit down and wait then I'm
gonna go focus on other things because
if I sit down and wait and focus on
other things and wait for somebody to
come they're grinding they're getting
ready while I'm focused on businesses
focused on not in the gym focusing on
things that are gonna make me money
outside of fighting yeah to where that's
where people kind of slip up I feel like
so
you know we're gonna see after this
fight you know I gotta I got a tough
test against Adriana Marius now we could
pass on that one bit and I don't I don't
mean to put you on the spot I'm not
looking let's I'm not a journalist I'm
not trying to get an answer out of you
I'm just trying to put myself in your
shoes like I don't know what else
there for him to do it's like all right
like check check check like when you
were first getting started and someone
was like Hey dude here's gonna be your
resume when you retire you're like holy
[__] what it's like yeah that's all yeah
you know so I I just I don't know what
you do but you're you're one of the guys
you know again I we we have a million
fives come through the the thick boy
studios here there's some guys where I'm
like oh you know like after they retire
I don't know what the hell holding mitts
go go hold mits out of UFC you know gym
you know there's some guys where I'm
like I don't know what he's gonna do
maybe she keep fighting your guy do not
worry about ever ever you're if you want
to you could be the next DC as far as
you know the way DC's parlayed his
career and he's kind of you know he's
he's the blueprint for guys man at your
level and he's so fantastic as an
analyst if you wanted to do that DJ
could do that when it comes to video
games you have a huge you know footprint
in the video games I'm sure there's
something there for you there's a
million things for you to do man
thanks man I appreciate that yeah and I
I feel uh uh you hit a spot on the the
head with going to be an analyst for one
Championship I've already done one uh
one of those uh the Amazon Prime show in
Thailand with uh Stewart Bond and
chingez and they've already asked me to
come back they're like hey we would love
to have you come back and you know be
part of a broadcast
so that's definitely an opportunity and
then you know obviously the gaming world
the YouTube's taking off and I've even
thought about having you know me and him
have thought about having our own
podcast just me him chopping it up a lot
of people like our our insight to mixed
martial arts I love it I love it you
guys watched it I think you guys watched
your fight right you watch both of your
fights dude I'm in and you guys talking
about the you guys breaking down cards
I'm in dude I'm in yeah if I get invest
in something I'd invest in a podcast of
you and Henry cejudo man yeah so we
there's a lot of options you know we
just gotta but once again when you
decide to go down that route that takes
a lot of energy takes a lot of setup
takes a lot of commitment that takes
away from can't do both you know you
can't have them both no you can't do
both like I'm able to I'm able to do the
YouTube by myself which has been going
pretty good but you know to do a podcast
and a YouTube and a full-time athlete
and wife and kids that's your your
Something's Gonna Give and I'm not gonna
give them my wife and kids you know and
then so you got to decide what it is and
that's what that's where all this comes
from like the whole Narrative of you
know this could be my last fight because
you know at the day I ask myself if I
can make as much money fighting doing
something else would I do it nine out of
ten times yes I would I would miss the
competition aspect of it but I can get
the competition aspect of that same
feeling cut weight competing by doing
Brazilian jitsu why might I take any you
know potential shots to the Head CTE
anything like that correct so that's
where that could come on like just like
Chad minus he got done fighting I'm sure
he probably made I don't know I'm gonna
say six figures doing bare knuckle
fighting and he's like I don't need to
do this anymore I I there's stuff I can
do that I put my energy into that's
paying me just as much or if not more
than bare Norco fighting so that's where
all that simple I get it brother 100 and
with Chad Mendes he's one of those guys
who I always root for guys when they
blow up outside of when they leave the
fine career right I always root for the
guys which admin is he's flying under
the radar man but I don't think people
realize how much he's killing it with
his hunting he does the hunting trips
the fishing trips the fishing absolutely
I mean was he was doing that Edition
tits or something what is it
that's a strip club Miami my bad
yeah yeah but he was working on that I
remember you know because we shared some
cars together back in WC and the UFC and
I remember he was working on that back
then right like like Floyd's gonna be
his Exit Plan already back then when he
was fighting for World titles you know
and now you know fast forward the Bronco
fighting he just made a nice check and
if it you know the feathers is taking
off and now it's like perfect I got six
figures I'm gonna take you know 25
percent of this put it in my uh my thing
to expand my business those are the
athletes that we all should look to and
be inspired they taking another passion
of theirs to build I mean even you you
got your podcast phone you do your stand
up yeah like those are things your
economy's got his you know whiskey he
can come back and fight if he wants or
he doesn't have to those are the
athletes we wanted to inspire that's why
I want to like I those athletes inspire
me to start thinking about things
outside of fighting and that's where all
that narrative comes from is that people
need to understand you know yes fighting
is great it's good money it's easy money
but you're all also you know risking
your health you're also risking your
brand you're also risking the
opportunity for this guy who beat you to
build off of your brand like I mean
there's so many things that go into it
so but yeah I mean
I mean there's there's two I not because
it's one Championship is different
weight classes but still 135 and 135
it's going down this weekend man because
you got you yeah right yeah you you got
Mariah's then you got Al Joe and Henry
sahuto how how you think uh your boy
Henry sudo does come back after three
year layoff
you know I think he's gonna do good I
train with them and you know I watched
the UFC countdown on what they said it
made sense you know his three-year
layoff wasn't you know a layout that you
would think that somebody would have you
know he had to Grado he had uh Shane
Willi he had uh jury there and he also
had Jon Jones he had myself yeah I think
everybody who's been there me in
particular Pike got the most actual
physical training of me like fighting
sparring grappling or whatnot so he's
still sharp I think the biggest thing
he's gonna have to overcome in battle is
having that three years off come back as
a competitor going against the guy who's
Alderman Sterling who's no clouds tall
foot away class great Grappler loves you
know the biggest thing before Al Joe
went and bought uh Peter Young the
biggest thing I said about aljo that was
the Turning program is that he realized
what he was good at which was being a
backpack do whatever you can to get on
somebody's Back Body triangle and just
murder him there that's where he's
special and you get your back he's
special
they special though so now he dictated
his whole game about getting to that
point and that's where I think it makes
him dangerous and that's why I told
Henry I said dude at the end of the day
you move better on your feet you're
faster and you have better Rhythm than
him the only thing I'm worried about is
that don't let him get on your back if
he gets on your back then it's gonna be
a longer night for you and you know it's
gonna be a great fight but I'm going for
you know hearing obviously because you
know we're buddies and you know we train
together
yeah I assume you're gonna pick uh Henry
and I I can see him getting it done the
only thing that I'm a little hesitant
with Henry is if you look at the stats I
think Henry's 36 you look at the stats
of a 36 year old fighting for World
title it's like one in 60. it's not good
you've seen that he's seen that
good
he said that word me a little bit it
worries me a little bit but I'm not a
big odds guy you know because when it
comes to Henry cejudo what what makes
him an outlier is here you don't become
a gold medalist in the Olympics a two
division you know champion in the UFC
and you know ringra stuff like that I'm
not worried about that for him I'm just
the only caveat there it is a three-year
layoff aljo's been getting better and
aljo also has this giant chip on his
shoulder and I don't know I can I get
why with the Peter Young stuff like that
the lack of respect that guy gets I
don't know what it's gonna take because
even if he beats so who don't people and
go three year layoff so who those old
man he's still not gonna get respect
after this
yeah it's the same with me I've done the
same thing my whole entire career you
know let's get back to that one at 1 and
60 that uh that interesting number of
odds I read that too because I thought I
found that category as well because I
won the world title at 35 years old so
yeah
that's when temperature is an account
whatever right so oh um and me 36 years
old defending the belt and I think that
you know that number comes from like as
you get older it is a lot harder to keep
up with the younger crowd what are you
34 30 28 whatever it may be
so those odds those numbers are
absolutely real but I think for Henry
you know it's that through your layoff
he is going to get time to miss Sterling
but like you said he is intelligent he
is able to make adjustments just as
myself I can make adjustments uh how
long the the fight game as well so
I think
um it's just gonna be interesting to see
how it unfolds and plays
yeah I'm excited for it I can't wait
I'll be in Denver at your will in
Broomfield at your fight I'll be there
man front row probably cheering like a
little cage rat just like a group in the
hell
um I'm excited for it man and it's the
first time because one of the advantages
of it being here in the states is now
your your family can actually come
because they're not flying to Singapore
and wherever the hell else one
championship in Asia is holding events
so the kiddos are coming to this fight
yep uh the kiddos are coming uh Tyrone
and Maverick they're coming and they're
super excited everybody's gonna be their
father-in-law dancing everybody's coming
out for this fight how old are the
kiddos
they're nine and eight
okay so they they're aware of Dad's a
badass dad's one of the goats you know
but they have they been to a fight
before I'm sure when they're younger
no they haven't but they see me lose
um when I fight Henry and when he when I
got knocked out you know they're like oh
well you know I tell them I was like
that this is for money so whatever
happens remember when I step in that
cages to provide for you guys to pay for
whatever your passions are and I've seen
them compete in Jiu Jitsu so I've seen
them lose and they come off the mat
trying to say hey dude it's fine you
know so for me uh I carry myself as a
man but respect you know I I give ass
whoopings and I also take them so you
know I
I'm sure there I found they're prepared
for whatever happens in a cage remember
Daddy loves you I'll be fine yep yep
dads can be fine dad's also one of the
greatest of all times so shut your
little mouth also you know what I'm
saying like watch three years kid here's
a funny one uh my daughter she's four
and she plays video games with me when
she watches me play and she goes see
Daddy you're still sort of like you know
I'm one of the fastest [__]
you see that you're so slow yeah okay
okay
um and the the kiddos there I'm assuming
they're in uh like you said they're
doing Jiu Jitsu or they're playing other
sports too are they gravitating towards
fighting
uh juicy J2
um they're gravitors uh other sports
um Tyron wants to do track and then
Maverick wants to do uh soccer and
they're both gonna do football so you
know I wanted YouTube to be able to
defend themselves because all fights I
believe end up underground and there's
also a sense of discipline in it as well
yes and you rank out you learn and you
know who knows what their lives are
going to be when they get older but I
wanted to be able to defend himself and
I think them to a football and soccer
and uh running track which is help
overall the athletic ability and are the
the kiddos have your genetics are they
are they big kids are they smaller kids
what are we talking about here it's
mixed Terence built like my wife
um long long legs long torso and then
Mavericks built like me short uh you
know that yeah back to you but it's just
elongated and then 10 I think TANF is
probably the most athletic one out of
all of them so far and four years old
yeah it's interesting to see too when
the the difference between the kiddos
you know like my son yeah he's like both
my kids are big you know they're big I'm
big my girl's super athletic so my kids
he's a tank man and he just wanted to
play soccer because his buddies are
playing soccer and he he's really good
at because he's athletic but you know
he's just a big dude out there and then
hook up you know they're awful they they
I think they've lost six games in a row
so and I gotta take him like God damn it
so we get upset
look it upset I'm just like I'm like man
don't tell your mom this but you're not
gonna play soccer dude you're too big
for soccer bro this isn't for you it's
gonna help your footwork because he
wants to play football I'm like it's
gonna help in football but outside that
man soccer ain't your path bro yeah he's
half Mexican so he gravitates towards
football but like her basketball I'm
sorry soccer but I'm like dude ditch
that Mexican side bud you even play
football
yeah I love that I love that hey you
can't teach size that's one thing that's
you know for basketball and football
depending on how tall you are or how big
you are you know you can't teach size no
man but you've you've handled it well
with your size because with with people
and I'm sure you inspire a lot of a lot
of dudes because when you're a shorter
athlete there's not a ton of options
like football wasn't in the you know in
the cards for you basketball sure as
hell not you know so it's like there's
there's a few things you can do
obviously kids gravitate towards
wrestling and for you you got to inspire
a lot of dudes who you know are they're
smaller people
yeah a lot of guys ate a lot of ants
they grab they grab they get a lot of
inspiration from me you know a lot of
people who are five three five five you
know five foot short teams you're the
short King you know kids being able to
go out there and provide for my family
and not let hype be a limitation to what
we can do and perform so I I'm totally
happy with running that flag to the bank
and letting people know like hey dude
yeah you're five two the screw thing
about you know Combat Sports you're
finding someone who's your size boxing
two
um boxing I would say mixed martial arts
anything kickboxing will retire the ones
that you can actually make a living off
of um if you're good and successful at
the highest level
you know what's interesting I was at the
press conference when one Championship
was announcing like they're coming to
America that giant press conference all
you guys were at and I saw Marias there
he is not a short King he's giant dude I
was like I was like who was that like
that's who DJ's friend like what the f
the hell he's huge dude isn't he big he
has to be the biggest guy you fought
we got him and Tim Elliott and uh Domino
Cruz so you know it's funny it's very
interesting I just feel like I'm a dense
guy right because when I look at the 125
pound champion uh the straw weight uh
Jared Brooks like I'm a little bit
taller than him but I'm also just
thicker than yeah
I'm just big even like you know all all
of the strawberry guys that I've been
next to we're all the same height but
I'm just [__] just more dense so you
know Adriana he's a five eight you know
not very big legs long legs long torso
big upper body but this lower body is
not like stacked or whatever
um Everybody carries their weight
totally different but yeah he's
definitely a big boy
yeah I mean I'll end this uh pretty soon
brother I know you gotta chill and get
ready for this fight and hang out in
Denver but uh yeah I think what's
interesting too about this fight this
this being the the rubber match here
it's not like both fights were dominant
one way or the other like you you you
two fight man you know what I'm saying
like that first fight could have went
your way easily the second fight he he
had some success and then you finished
them off like it's not like you know
you're not looking at a situation where
one dominated the entire time then the
rematch one dominated like it's a it's a
toss-up man it's a good freaking fight
yeah I mean we you put it that way you
look at the first fight like it was me
trying to get to him I got in my clinch
went in a nice knee to the liver
um and then he ended up I don't know if
he caught my kick and then he pulled
guard and was going for a leg work he
was able to reverse that get on top of
me and then that was the end of the
first round and then the second round
came out late kicking moving looking
good it's got that uppercut and that
need to ground an opponent yeah that was
it right and then you look at my fight
second fight going out to throw a body
kicks he catches it again takes me down
I beat him up on my back we're fighting
then eventually he started to slow down
I'm smoking faster and right hand flying
into the cage so I think the surface can
be the same thing you know I'm gonna go
out there I'm gonna take a risk push the
pace see what happens see if I can find
an open or career I'm gonna create an
opening I'm gonna create an opening and
then I'm gonna try to put them away
again yeah it's a scrap man is there was
there any point because I'm sure it was
you know obviously a risk going over to
one Championship leaving UFC is a big
risk and we've had guys do it before
from the UFC and didn't work out they go
over and they just get their ass
whooping this other organization and
they kind of drift off into you know the
either we don't really hear from was
there is there any point when you're
fighting one Championship where you're
like oh I made the right choice like
obviously now we can say that in
hindsight it's like of course there's
the right choice was there it was there
a certain moment or was there something
where you like Yep this was the right
choice
I I knew I knew once I started the The
Motions of trying to get out of my
contract that was the right choice the
reason why I say that is because you
know what you have at that time UFC you
didn't know if they were going to keep
125 they're getting rid of it that's
right you know the weather's in the best
relationship between me and the UFC not
saying it was bad but there was a number
of transparency of like what they wanted
to do right so with that being said and
there was almost a ceiling at that time
in 2018 there was a standing on like how
much money I could make it was like
you're at 350 and you're in S5 10 10 10
or whatever and then you you get
pay-per-view points one time so you know
obviously things could be different if I
was like I'm giving you points on all my
tile defenses I ended up on a Conor car
or Jones card or would you sell the [__]
out then things would be there but that
wasn't the case so for me just to have
the opportunity to be able to travel
abroad uh fight for one Championship
have the opportunity to do something
different like the mixed rules fight
with rotting which is a huge I love that
I think in my legacy and everybody
around the world about that I till this
day I still think that's my biggest
fighter one Championship because it was
something out of the out of the ordinary
everybody knew who writing was like my
friends you know they don't watch
fighting but they know who rotting was
he can't walk the streets in Thailand
rating is Tom Cruise of Thailand massive
yeah he's massive dude massive so you
know when I was rated by Adrian the
first time they're like who's that I'm
like oh he's a Brazilian great guy
amazing athlete he's a champion even the
second time me about to fight Adriana I
was like who you fighting I was like
Adriana I was like who's that even a
third time like who you finding my
Adriana again they're like who [__] is
that and I'm like this guy just beat and
he goes oh okay okay or I say rotten
they're like you find that crazy
[__] yeah like everybody knew he
was
when they brought that fight to me I was
like yep I'll take it because you know
you see a lot of people now in this
order mixed martial arts are like I want
to fight the biggest things that's you
know like I want to fight the biggest
names in the in in the sport and you
know that's what Connor does I Conor's
like who's the biggest thing like I'd
rather fight him and just test myself
because I know it's going to do very
well but never as wise so
no I pre you you've done it the right
way man and I I thought it was
interesting again we had uh I mean
chatri have worked together before and I
met him briefly once no I had him in
studio here you know I was with him for
about two hours dude I would have ran
through a wall for that dude and you
look at his background you know Harvard
educated you know him being an immigrant
living out of a briefcase with his mom
sleeping on the ground in a sleeping bag
started one Championship from nothing
it's like oh yeah this is why he's
having the success like rotating is a
bad mama jama man yeah absolutely I mean
tractor series is absolutely amazing
what he's been able to do with the sport
of uh you know one Championship I don't
want to say mixed martial arts because
it's not one Championship isn't just
mixed martial arts but what he's been
able to do for martial arts in general
and the highest at the highest level you
know I know a lot of Grapplers who
grapple uh you they don't make great
money you know unless you go off and you
know create a DVD and you beat the
Fanatics or whatever you're having all
that stuff like Gordon Ryan and all
those guys but to give those guys a
platform to be able to compete and make
good money it's awesome you know no
other organization is doing it so why
not they even Muay Thai or eating
kickboxing
because those guys a platform to go to
compete and make great money yeah he's
changing the game and when he was out
here I mean obviously the news now is uh
Francis and Gano didn't sign with one
Championship like they they both decided
it wasn't gonna work out it drives me
nuts now I assume Francis has something
up his sleeve he's supposed to announce
he he's gonna sign another promotion
maybe it's that boxing thing but I just
thought what chatri offered him is was I
was like oh this is a no-brainer this
this is a done deal when I heard he
didn't take him like that's insane to me
I don't know where else he's gonna go or
he's going to be able to beat that deal
yeah I think the hardest thing you know
for Francis is that if anybody you know
when I talked to Eddie Alvarez he says
Eddie says he always when he signs a
deal he says how what's the fastest way
for me to become a free agent when he
said to me I was like
why is that and he goes because I always
believe in myself I always better myself
right so you think about it Eddie
average is hot right now he's hot he
just had to Eddie believe me brand new
he's always gonna fight his ass off yeah
the bare knuckle fighting championship
right he's hot stock right now in in
North America everybody's talking about
him now he's a free agent he can do
whatever he wants he's not tied down to
one organization so maybe for Francis he
has been he's spot for the one of the
biggest organizations in the world he's
made great money now he's a free agent
you know I just saw like his last fight
was what 400 days ago but you know I
don't know what the logistics Logistics
the money-wise he was you know asking
for one Championship or I don't know
what that conversation was but you know
you wait one time they fight in boxing
10 million 15 million you're not going
to make that any MMA promotion at all
one time deal one-time gig you fight you
sign a contract you fight you're done
you walk away you're not tied you're not
locked down do whatever you want I think
that means more to him than being under
any like UFC one Championship I think
that's where if that was him that's what
I would be striving for it's like I'm
looking for that one payday where I
signed one one deal fight get paid and
it's okay now [__] man I want to mix my
shorts go do something else that's what
I think he's looking for yeah I assume
he has that out there otherwise he
wouldn't talk to your boy Chachi about
what they offered him
talk to Chocolate you'll see it and
you're like wait I've never seen some
[__] like this I was like yeah wait what
oh my God it's not it's not my place to
out what the deal the numbers were it's
nuts dude nuts absolutely nuts you're
like holy [__] I'll talk and I'll find
out I'll find out do it brother yeah
cause I I assume Francis does have that
some sort of guarantee in the boxing
world to turn this he has to he he
absolutely if would you tell me if it
was what you're telling me that he has
to right and I said he's got
I'll tell you off air so I don't want to
put chachi's business out there but when
off here I'll tell you it's it's nuts
dude I was like offline okay I'll fight
him for that much money I'll do it right
now yeah I don't need training camp
nothing sign me up dude you know but
yeah yeah man you're doing the right way
man you got a beautiful family you're
one of the goats last question it's
obviously it's in this we'll end on this
it's not up to you to for for you to
decide if you're the the grace of all
time what the fans in the media let you
know right but you're always in the
conversation it's always one or two one
or two all the time who is on your list
let's just go top three goats if you had
to pick
let's take you out of it you're number
one let's say you're number one take you
out
um GSP uh John Jones and then
I would you know I'm gonna say habit
like those those three when I sit back
I've been pondering about this too
and punter about it because I always
said you know and I have a lot of my
athletes who are who are the good as
well you know him received was right
there yeah he is definitely the greatest
combat he's uh he is the greatest common
athlete of all time uh gold little melas
fly away depending the belt Spanaway
dependent come back again
um you know the only thing I'll say from
here is like I'd love to see him get a
submission you know when I look at all
three of those guys GSP he's knocked
people out he's got a submission he's
got a decision whatever uh Jon Jones
same thing same thing even with um you
know I I don't know if he's actually a
kid somebody with I'm cold but he
submitted people you know so those guys
have showcase everything for me and
they've and they've been Champions you
know I would love to see more from Habib
but I think the stipulation is what
happened to his father and you know him
and his injuries too kind of like
postpone him like fighting a lot so but
yeah I'll put those three yeah the only
knock on khabib he just didn't do it
long enough right like his Reign wasn't
long enough when he was the title holder
that's the only knocking him my
argument's always for Jon Jones because
he's at a higher weight class the level
and the the the room for air for him to
you know get finished is so much bigger
than the the rest of the guys that you
mentioned so I I was and you look at the
love of competition that Jon Jones had
especially early on after beat Shogun
it's just like murders roof who's who
now granted yeah the the heavier weights
always have you know bigger Stars a lot
of the times so yeah but yeah and then
obviously John at heavyweight now just
adds more to his resume
yeah absolutely absolutely but yeah you
can get no argument here man you're one
of the goats you know this every
everyone knows this and I'm excited to
see it live Friday in action in
Broomfield Colorado my man I appreciate
you taking the time and I will see you
out there brother you keep that skin
moisturized I'm gonna go toss on some
moisturizer right freaking now dude
Jesus Christ we know it you you know I
know it all right brother appreciate you
likewise
of all time here we go the Epic Trilogy
fight for the first time ever Demetrius
Johnson defends the one flyweight World
Championship in the USA
one fight night ten Johnson versus
Mariah's three on Prime video